liebe kollegen kollegen heute gestern
vor 80 jahren überfiel die wehrmacht die
sowjetunion und mit dem angriff weil sie
sich der in polen und im balkan feldzug
begonnene vernichtungskrieg aus
nirgendwo in europa schreckte die
deutsche besatzung herrschaft vor terror
gewalt und verbrechen gegen
menschlichkeit zurück auf besonders
grausame art aber wütete sie im osten
und südosten europas
getrieben von ihrer rassistischen
ideologie folgten die
nationalsozialisten dem vorsatz menschen
und kulturen auszulösen in ihren worten
juden bolschewisten und slawen zu
vernichten
mehr als 27 millionen menschen verloren
ihr leben
mehr als die hälfte waren zivilisten
am freitag hat der herr bundespräsident
ihrer gedacht
in der letzten sitzungswoche hat der
deutsche bundestag in einer vereinbarten
debatte an die grausamkeit des deutschen
angriffs auf die sowjetunion erinnert
und wir haben bekräftigt den opfern
dieses krieges seien angemessenen platz
in unserer erinnerungskultur ein zu
wollen und dem dient auch unser
beschluss hier in berlin eine
dokumentations- bildungs und
erinnerungsstätte zur geschichte des
zweiten weltkriegs zu errichten
das gedenken in deutschland und in allen
nachfolgestaaten der sowjetunion
verdeutlicht wie wichtig der respekt für
die unterschiedlichen erfahrungen und
die damit verbundenen gefühle ist als
grundlage für den austausch und für eine
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit ohne die
sich der friede und die stabilität auf
dem kontinent nicht dauerhaft wird
sichern lassen um die wir uns deshalb
immer wieder neu bemühen
essen hier waren allerdings das zeigt
nicht zuletzt die geschichtspolitischen
betrachtungen mit denen der russische
staatspräsident auf die innenpolitische
debatte in unserem land einzuwirken
versucht wir waren schon einmal
viehweider erinnerung so viel ist sicher
lebt nicht nur ford lebt nur fort wenn
nachfolgende generationen sie pflegen
auch dafür setzt sich der bundestag ein
in diesem jahr beschäftigt sich die
internationale jugendbegegnung mit den
verbrechen die das
nationalsozialistische deutschland im
zweiten weltkrieg an der
zivilbevölkerung verübt hat traditionell
findet die jugendbegegnung zum tag des
gedenkens am 27 januar statt
sie musste dieses jahr wiederholt
verschoben werden und jetzt freue ich
mich die teilnehmerinnen teilnehmer
heute bei uns begrüßen zu können
im namen aller mittels haushalt begrüße
ich sie herzlich
[Applaus]
wir deutsche stehen die der
verantwortung lehren aus der
vergangenheit zu ziehen und unsere
freiheitlichen werte zu verteidigen
die menschenrechte und das völkerrecht
und die darauf gründende
sicherheitsarchitektur die uns und
unsere verbündeten ein
und sie ist die garantie für den frieden
in europa und in der welt